I feel like I'm a lot I'm a medicine to
a lot of people around the world
oh for sure rule comedy do those little
one-minute Eclipse I grew up watching
Sheneneh you know Martin Lawrence I grew
up watching one Jamie Foxx and I've
always been a die-hard fan of Tyler
Perry Madea talked about the first time
you met him and looking up to him and
Madea Tyler's amazing I talked to him
every other day I have some things that
I can't say that I'm working on I'm
literally like about two or three things
I'm I'm planning a partner with Tyler on
but I can't say fortunately I can't know
if it's social media TV film it is not
social media and I'm trying to think no
it's not none of them are social media
okay none of social media so we're
breaking into you know small screen big
screen barriers Madea is going to be
retiring soon aka they're killing Madea
off so it feels like Tyler Perry may be
passing the torch to TT is that true
[Laughter]
she's good I'll just say wait on it you
gotta just wait on it I'll say it's
coming soon okay and really cool it's
coming some other holidays are next year
it's gonna be right after the holidays
okay right out the holidays Surprise
them in the new year she dragged it out
of me y'all so when it comes to Tyler
Perry in those heart-to-hearts that
you've had what advice as he passed
along to you you know when he passes on
that torch I see happening Tyler has
given me amazing advice yeah one of
which is to just keep going after what I
love and do it fearlessly I feel like
the beginning of my social media career
I got a lot of a lot of negative
feedback now there's a lot of people who
didn't like trolls yeah there are a lot
of trolls but that was also a small
amount of people that did love what I
did and it
literally turn out to be to this day
like a big number cuz I kept going and I
kept going after my dream and he
continues to just poor me and encourage
me to just keep chasing whatever it is
that I love to do and that's content PT
do you love me do you love me TT is
looking for love is he going to be
successful by the end of season one no
way TT is tired of being lonely TT is so
tired of being lonely I may have look
you just gotta stay tuned it's my first
show ever and on the network they have
over about seven seventy shows and my
show is the number one show on the
network I'm super excited
Christ I was I'm gonna be honest I just
like it's like there's so many good
content creators out there there's a
made 8 day storm king badge Jessica
Vanessa T they have so many greats on
the platform are we gonna get greenlit
for a season two I got greenlit for a
season two in Atlanta actually okay you
know I got the boys so TJ is ready
I know TT is looking for love but it's
quite half someone that he's in love
with I am married to this person called
the bag I'm so just hungry for just just
just to keep growing my BOB my platform
and and what I'm doing is to continue to
put out great content for my supporters
I'm taking it on to I'm attacking a
YouTube space so I'm excited about that
you talked about Sheneneh and that made
me think okay Martin reboot is happening
has Martin Lawrence reached out to you
have you reached out to him
I am absolutely scared because I feel
like that is the biggest thing huh I
grew up on Sheneneh yeah interestingly
enough I was in the car with my director
with diamine and he said clay like let's
take advantage you have all of these
followers let's get Tyler Perry's
attention and I was like Tyler Perry is
too busy eating we'll see like if I post
something
do you know what you know and I'll put
up a picture tt and Maddie and I say
y'all this is my dream I want to meet
Tyler they tagged him so much the next
morning and that's how I have that
connection with Tyler Perry so I think I
want to do one more I thought I was
about to get on your nerves Martin
you're ready let's do it because I could
see that really be so much fun it would
be so much fun let's start from the
beginning because I feel like this TT
didn't happen overnight Quay didn't
happen overnight and a lot of people it
starts when they're young what was your
first memory of being someone that you
know what's kind of a class clown or
comedian I literally grew up getting
kicked out of class so I feel like
social media my followers Milo 3.8
million followers that's my classroom
and I feel like I can entertain them any
time of the day
so you were a class clown
looking back did your parents see it in
you that you were just a performer it's
one of my dad wanted me to be a
basketball player I ain't got no type of
real fun so he was a live in support and
my mom you know I've always had a
passion for helping people I went to
school to major in social work and I
feel like with social work we the
mission is to like help people through
issues and stuff like that and I feel
like I'm still doing it through social
media that's what you do been a healing
experience for you or is it just the
feedback that feeds you what keeps you
going every day as a creator that's a
really good question
I lost my dad about two years ago and I
felt like if I didn't have my supporters
my fans on Instagram I don't know what I
would have done because that was a very
dark time in my life and because so many
people was just like come on quit don't
give up just give us some content we
ready to laugh and I'm ready for you to
make me laugh I was I was happy to
continue to just to do back what do you
think that your dad would say now seeing
all the success that you have my dad
would be so so happy to know that I have
a restaurant today cuz my dad passed
away my dad passed away around the time
when teaching really started to bone and
I don't know what do you be thinking
today like his son is really out here
just chasing his dreams and I would die
to know about how he feels to know that
I have a restaurant honestly I want to
know like I feels about that to be on
him I feel like he would say he's proud
because then that's huge thank you for
catching me before I still had a tear in
town but yes crab Queens I'm super
excited about that so are we gonna be
expanding to LA I'm actually expanding
to LA nice and too much for opening up
in Inglewood and downtown okay and soon
after we're taking it to Atlanta okay so
watch out boiling crab watch out hot and
juicy watch out y'all watch out brother
crab my hottie juicy we bring in a real
spy
so in January we have some big things
happening a release in my master class I
wanted to I wanted to give back to the
people that support and love my content
there's so many people that are just
eager to just get their social media
career started and I love to pour into
those people and encourage them on how
to maximize and grow your platform I'm
assuming this masterclass is not free so
how can we get the details another life
is free but I do care about my follow so
I'm saving them a lot of money it's
inexpensive it's gonna be a digital
master class
[Music]
[Applause]